[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
for today's video i'm going to be
discussing one of the unforgivable
curses
more specifically i'm going to be
discussing avada kadavra
and its properties we know avada kadavra
as the killing curse
the staple spell of lord voldemort and
seemingly the go-to spell
for dark witches and wizards intent on
putting an end to their enemies
avada kadavra is a truly sinister spell
it is classified as unforgivable
by the ministry of magic along with
crucio aka the cruciatus curse
and imperia aka the imperious curse
these three curses were classified as
unforgivable in the year 1717
when the ministry of magic determined
that they were entirely
unsuitable to be freely used in the
wizarding world
at the same time the strictest penalties
were put in place
and attached to their use before 1717
we can only assume that they were
regarded just like any other spell
and while we don't have any information
to support this there must have been
some sort of catalyst
that made the ministry realize how truly
dangerous these spells were
eulek gamp was the minister for magic at
the time the spells were outlawed
with just one year left in his term
perhaps something happened
involving these spells that threatened
his position i can only imagine the
chaos that something like the imperious
curse
would cause in a government structure
like that the most notorious of the
unforgivable curses
of cadaver has a simple purpose it
causes the victim to instantly die
if you want to kill your victim then
this is a spell to use
upon uttering the incantation the spell
creates a blindingly intense green bolt
of light
and the victim simply drops dead however
one thing that is never properly
explained
is how avada kadava actually kills
people unlike many other spells
vada godov relieves no trace at all they
just
die so my question is how do they die
what's going on i'm going to start by
taking a look at the chapter
the riddle house from the gobbs of fire
the chapter that examines the murder of
the riddle family
in little hangalton the police had never
read an order report
a team of doctors had examined the
bodies and had concluded that none of
the riddles had been poisoned
stabbed shot strangled suffocated or as
far as they could tell
harmed at all in fact the report
continued in a tone of unmistakable
bewilderment
the riddles all appeared to be in
perfect health apart from the fact that
they were all dead
the doctors did note as though
determined to find something wrong with
the bodies
that each of the riddles had a look of
terror upon his or her face
but as the frustrated police said
whoever heard of three people frightened
to death
what this excerpt confirms entirely is
that the killing curse leaves no
physical trace the riddle family were
undoubtedly killed with avada kadavra
but they didn't have so much as a
scratch on them they were just
dead and it happened instantaneously so
what is the process
what does a spell do i know that some
people have made the argument that the
killing curse simply causes the organs
of the victim
to stop working stopping the functions
of certain organs particularly
the heart inducing a heart attack would
be a surefire way of killing someone
however if this were true then their
deaths would have been a little bit more
drawn out
whatever the killing curse does happens
instantly which is why the victims still
have the look of terror on their face
described by the police though it wasn't
something they could run with
the best way that police at the crime
scene could describe their deaths was
that they appeared to be frightened to
death
but of course in the muggle world that
isn't possible
so if it isn't physical then avada
kodava must have more of an
ethereal effect the soul is a common
theme in harry potter
we see it with voldemort and we see it
with dementors leveraging his own soul
voldemort tried to fragment it in order
to achieve immortality
and it resulted in his horcruxes pieces
of his soul
that he embedded into different objects
to stay alive
we also know that dementors suck the
soul out of their victims
leaving them in what seems to be an
almost state of limbo
alive but lifeless my theory is this
avada kadavra similar to the way the
dementor sucks out the soul of living
being
takes their soul from them however there
are a few key differences here
first of all avada kadavra actually
kills them
and dementors don't kill people they
just leave their victims with
very little i think the main difference
here is just the effectiveness in the
way that the soul
is taken from the body when a dementor
kisses someone
their soul is slowly taken from them in
a traumatic process
whereas with the vada kadavra i believe
that it happens instantaneously
as if it is ripped from the body i think
that if the soul is truly and entirely
taken from the body
then you will die it's just that
dementors leave a bit of soul in their
victims
just enough for them to suffer it seems
fitting for a creature like a dementor
to do something morbid like that
particularly as loved ones of those that
have been kissed will now have to
witness a shell of the person
they once knew thus creating more
sadness and depression
the very environment in which dementors
thrive i think
the concept of horcruxes is enough to
support the argument that the
soul is ultimately what keeps us alive
as even when voldemort's physical form
is entirely destroyed
a mere piece of his soul allows him to
continue existing
i think that's at least in harry potter
truly killing someone transcends
physicality
sure if the container of the soul our
bodies
is destroyed then that may mean there is
nowhere else for the soul to go
but as voldemort proved so long as your
soul is preserved in some kind of
physical object then you will continue
to live in a weird way
killing someone with the vaticandavra is
a much more humane way of ending their
life than say
leaving them to the dementors as in one
swift moment their life is over
it's not dragged on and though it may be
traumatic for say an instant
they truly won't suffer so i'm of the
impression that evada cadaver rips the
soul out of the body
but the next thing that i want to look
at is how the following excerpt gives a
good description of the effects of avada
kadavra
being cast there was a flash of blinding
green light
and a rushing sound as though a vast
invisible something
was soaring through the air
instantaneously the spider rolled over
onto its back
unmarked but unmistakably dead the part
that sticks out to me from this passage
is this idea of something vast and
invisible soaring through the air
and i think that it connects with the
notion of physicality that i discussed
earlier
conventionally when someone is killed
their physical form is killed by
physical means i.e someone is stabbed or
shot
and this causes their body to
effectively die
this is what the muggle police were
looking for given that ivarakudavra
strips the body of the soul suggesting a
sort of ethereal connection
i think that avada kadavra may actually
have a form beyond
the green light it's just not something
that can be witnessed on a physical
level
maybe it's just not something that can
be seen until you've transcended the
physical world
maybe to dementors ghosts and shades
like the ones harry interacts with via
the resurrection stone
nevada cadaver looks entirely different
getting really dark here
but perhaps avada kadavra summons the
dead who come to take away your soul
and bring it to the next level of
existence this may explain why there is
little understanding about the spell
seemingly even within the wizarding
community and why victims of the spell
appear to have been frightened to death
i can't imagine what it would be like
to have spirits surging towards you and
stripping you of your soul
anyway these are just some ideas that i
heard about perhaps the most discussed
spell
in all of harry potter it seems unusual
that voldemort's go too
is never explained in proper detail but
i do like that it leaves it open to
interpretation
what do you guys think of my theories
let me know in the comment section
below until next time it does not do to
dwell on dreams
and forget to live
[Music]
you